but the composition of bacteria in your
God different from my God so how to make
personalized
Medicine by making one yogurt that
contain the same proy so this is the
bunch of different challenges we need to
overcome to make that crazy dream come
true but I still wanted to Dream High
because that is why not because that me
potentially
help a lot of people become
happier so hello and welcome to the
Shiki science show where in this video I
speak with tasok moon associate
professor of energy environmental and
chemical engineering at Washington
University in St Louis he is an expert
in synthetic biology and metabolic
engineering and has published over 60
peer reviewed papers and also hosts the
synthetic biology young speak series
himself also a YouTuber here we speak
about his research and his amazing
applications from degrading plastic to
developing smart probiotics I hope you
enjoy our
conversation so hi tasok thank you for
joining me today and welcome to the
Shiki Science
Show hi uh thank you so much for
inviting me to this wonderful show thank
you thank you and so one of the reasons
why I got interested in your research is
that you're interested in synthetic
biology and so I thought initially it
would be good to ask what exactly is
synthetic biology and what parts of it
uh got you interested into the
field so that is so challenging
question because if you ask the same
question to different people you will
get the different answers you know I
would say thousand people will have
thousand different
answers
so I been in this fear
almost 20 years but still I try to
define the the what is synthetic biology
so I honestly don't know uh the field is
still evolving in some
sense but if
I am asked to
Define I would say synthetic biology
is some effort or or
fear that sort of engineer living system
in a programmable
way to achieve some practical
goal like you know solving Global
problem including climate crisis
medicine and also you know food shortage
and sustainable sustainable production
and also pollution problem Etc and so
how did you get interested in the field
in the first
place so that is interesting question
so if I go back
to
uh let's say go back to the college year
so I you know major in applied chemistry
and I didn't take any biology course in
high school except one basic course and
then somehow I fascinated by
biochemistry and I start to getting more
cours workk from another department that
is a microbiology and biology department
and then I was so
excited by the biology and also all the
secret and mystery of biology and then I
interest in biochemical engineering
because I'm in the
engineering department at the time so I
joined as a master student in
biochemical engineering laboratory and
then I joined the
company and
then I start to read a lot of papers not
necessarily my own you know fear in the
company to broaden my
Horizon and then two paper came to my
life that is actually seminar paper by
Jim
Carin that is about togle switch publish
in nature and another paper published in
the same year 2000 in nature that is the
by you know Michael alloy that is about
to the oscillating genetic circuit that
to paper is so simple but also very
elegant to describe
living system and that they call it
genetic circuit and then they Implement
that using very simple gen and put
together and then demonstrating some
genetic you know circuit like we see
from electronic system so that two paper
basically
fascinating me at the time more than 20
years ago and after I done my you know
industry experience I wanted to become a
PhD student so I join MIT and at the
time you know there was no synthetic
biology Professor but there was one
Professor working on metabolic
engineering that is
a one part of the synthetic biology I
believe so I join her Christal prer and
then I work on metabolic engineering but
still interest in hardcore synthetic
biology including genetic circuit
building and so on and then I lucky
enough to be trained in the first center
for synthetic biology in us that is a
called
simberg and then as a I call it simberg
key did I met a lot of Professor during
the annual
meetings uh at the time I talk many
Professor including Jay kering Adam Arin
Georgie Church you know all the big name
in synthetic biy and also Chris vo you
know he became my advisor for my posttop
work and then in his lab I learned a lot
about synthetic biology including
genetic circuit building and Def
factoring that is a process to simplify
genetic system using similar concept we
use in the computer science or
Electronics so that's how I became
synthetic biologist and after my
training I start my position here
2012 in St Louis you know working as
Professor here I see and so um I'm a
biochemist myself not an engineer so I'm
kind of interested to understand what
are the engineering principles you apply
to build these circuits in the sort of
biological
form so the the there are two keyword in
terms of synthetic biology why this is
the different from previous biology you
know
disciplines the first one is this one
Focus on
quantitive understanding using
mathematical
model so we use a lot of analysis but
mostly conative analysis and then we use
the some mathematical
model and then analyze and then after
that analysis we use that you
know Insight we GA and then we build
better model
in that way that model predict the
behavior of the biological system so
that's one keyword and second keyword I
would say is
application so this is a engineer
engineering field that's a different
from biology because before biology is
all about
observation see how bird
fly you how you know animal gathered
together but we just observe and then if
you wanted to observe inside you
probably remember you cut your frog you
know in high school or middle school and
then see what's inside so this is all
about the biology before but now
synthetic biology we wanted to
understand biology by
building sort of living system or
mimicking living system and analyze
after building some small portion of the
biological system so that is the key
difference and then the goal is at the
end of the application to solve Global
problem including as I mentioned earlier
you know climate crisis food
shortage and
pollution sustainable
production and also medicine as you know
I mean you know we already seen product
of synthetic biology that is actually
covid vaccine I believe so that is two
key difference between traditional
biology and synthetic biology yeah that
makes sense and so also there's a lot of
excitement about synthetic biology at
the moment because as you mentioned for
all of these different applications and
so I know from your own research you've
been well you've done several different
projects but one of them's been uh
identifying a bacterial strain that was
able to break down plastic and I was
just wondering if you could talk about
project and what that
involved sure so
we our paper publish and that paper
focus
on P that is the you know you probably
already know I mean the PT ble you know
you probably use a lot but this is huge
problem because this PT basically
consist I mean this PT
basically around 12% of all the solid
waste in the world I'm talking about 12%
of entire solid waste the solid waste
include metal and plastic some other you
know waste from the uh food industry and
also the you know parping industry all
together and 12% is a lot because you
know plastic is so light but still you
know Weight Wise the
12% so we want to solve that
problem and the reason we chose
PT because PT is probably the easiest
plastic we could break down using simple
chemistry if you remember your Chemistry
you know high school chemistry PT is
polyester and the Esther bone is easily
broken if you add acid or
base like NaOH and then you just need to
heat it up and then if you heat it up up
to
150°
Celsius basically the polymer Bond Break
by
hydrolysis and then that individual
small molecule we call it
monomer that is just chemical but
unfortunately one of the chemical has
automatic green and actually that is a
bit toxic to most of the
bacteria but our lab basically
spend more than 10
years to identify some bacteria tolerate
those kind of toxic chemical by using
soal adaptive
Evolution that is basically the process
you put bacteria into the some toxic
environment or harsh environment and
then slowly increase the harshness or
toxic level of the compound and then
improve the tolerance level of the
bacteria in that way you could use that
bacteria for for example bio
remediation it potentially clean up our
environment so that is what we've done
last more than 10 years and then luckily
we chose the right compound 10 years ago
and then some of the bacteria among
2,000 different
stock mutant in our
refrigerator actually has
ability to break down or
utilize PT
monomer we if we break down the polymer
into the smaller molecule this bacteria
use that monomer as Sol carbon Source
even though that chemical is toxic to
other
bacteria so that's how we identify or
discover new bacterium that utilize
waste as a sole carbon source and then
this bacteria also amazingly produce
some high value
chemical including
lopine and I believe you already heard
about lopine lopine is the one of the
food ingredient coming from
tomato but we chose ropin production by
engineering or putting more gene or you
know
manipulating the gene in the bacteria to
produce more
lopin because I wanted to solve problem
of
plastic but at the same time I want to
solve the another biggest problem that
is a food shorty or
conceptual
unacceptable
practice that currently happening
because many company produce
lopin by
extracting lopin from the
Tomato the Tomato should be something to
eat rather than something to play with
as you know probably your father or Mom
used to say don't play with your food
but many company actually play with food
to
making you know
Revenue but at the same time I want to
say many people in developing country
like Africa suffering from food stage
and many people die at this
moment not necessarily because they
don't have tomato but I believe
conceptually using food to make some
chemical that's not conceptually right
so we wanted to develop this
technology basically converting plastic
waste
into high value chemical like lopin that
might solve the two problem including
food shortage or food
inequality at the same time solving
pollution problem that is because of the
plastic waste so that's one thing I want
to mention for that specific paper you
just yeah no it's really incredible that
it's not just yeah consuming the plastic
but actually converting that to useful
substances in this case lopine um which
as you mentioned is really high value so
now that you have this sort of like
system established by using combination
of adaptive Evolution and um this
somewhat genetic engineering approaches
how flexible is the system to then
generates many other different compounds
of high interest um and likewise using
maybe different types of monomers to
begin
with yeah so that's great question so as
I mentioned PT alone basically comprise
12% of the solid waste but still PT is
one of the Plus waste we need to deal
with so right now you know since the
first paper published actually we start
that project around six years ago but
you know several years ago we transition
after we see PT utilization or
valorization or upcycling is working we
wanted to solve bigger problem that is a
mixed plastic problem I'm not sure about
you Cas system but in us we do not
recycle well in terms of plastic we put
every you know
recycled recyclable plastic into one big
waste
bin so separation is issue you put
polyethylen in that bean polypropylen
into the that one there are too many
packing material that's mostly poly
Stylin and this is BAS these are the key
plastic
waste uh including the P so now we
developed
technology not only utilizing PT but now
we have ability to utilize PT Plus p
polyethylen polypropylen and poly styl
and all together and same concept we
break down that into smaller molecule in
that way
bacteria potentially eating those
smaller molecule but still those
molecules is toxic but we have 2,000
different stock of the muton bacteria or
tough guy the tough guy basically eating
those plastic breakdown compound and
then converting that into high value
compound such as lopin or potentially
making biodegradable
polymers including po you know pH that's
a biodegr polymer or we could even make
some other polymer like like know Lyon
66 or some other polymer using similar
concept the only thing we need to do is
of course optimize the process in that
way that's the economically buyable at
the same time we need to
engineer the pathway metabolic pathway
Gene so rather than making lopin we also
Chanel that waste or that's a nutrient
for the my bacteria
into some chemical we or polymer we
going to make and to do so we need to
change some G like delete some
unnecessary G that kind of competing
with my pathway or adding some gen that
has high activity in that way you making
more product of Interest so that's our
current
status after we saw those kind of
technology I actually start a
company translate the technology into
reality so I'm so excited so I form a
company and then the company name is the
moonshop bio why not my last name is
Moon Moon is
something we want need to try and that's
the mo bi yeah no it's a good name and
it's really impressive uh the work
you've achieved so far and so I mean you
make it sound somewhat trivial but I
imagine it's a lot of hard work and so I
mean what are the major bottlenecks that
you face when trying to build these
different uh
systems so the B leg of course is there
are many many bottle leg so the simple
bottle leg or probably the most
important one is when it comes to
making lopin out of
plastic and current lopin market is
basically uh you know food
ingredient uh that's a food supplement
we are so la or bsy so we rather take we
rather than taking
tomato you know people taking some peer
that contain a lot of vitamin and lop
and so on but the the conceptually you
know this is very difficult to convince
people to take the
PE but the ingredient coming from
waste so that's a market problem but if
you're thinking about another Market you
know ropin also use in the cosmetics
company because that's a red color so
cosmetic red color and also
antioxidant so there are many good
benefit having
lopin but that is a one you know Market
challenge but in terms of technological
challenge you know I wanted to say that
is something promising but this one is
literally six years of effort to just
show the demonstration or fruit of
concept demonstration at at this moment
this one is work by all my student and
Posta literally working every day day
and night because they are passionate
about solving Global problem including
pollution
problem and technological problem is we
demonstrate
making small amount of lopin out of the
plastic but the the amount right now is
Tiny is something like only millgram per
liter
scale but to make that commercially
viable we should achieve minimum gram
per liter scale in the final production
level so that means we need to improve
minimum several 1004
more Improvement but I believe you know
I'm also confident we could go there
because ropin production study more than
years and then we already achieved more
than 500 for improvement by just using
simple metabolic engineering
technology but with the technology
advanced month until now from milligram
per liter to G ler that might be
achievable I would say within next S 3
to 5 years time frame but still you know
that require lots of effort
student hours and post do spending day
and night and also you know I also need
to work with them to make that happen
but I'm very very
optimistic because
all the young people in my lab working
hard to solve this great important
problem then that might be achievable in
the future and then potentially if that
happen I retire early and then selling
the technology at the same time solving
all the global problem together yeah
that' be really cool to see that happen
especially within that time frame as
well but no I realize this be a lot of
work um obiously you mentioned like a
has like health benefits and I know that
I mean this is just one project of yours
we've really discussed so far you've
also done a lot of uh research on
developing like smart probiotics and so
wonder if you could elaborate on some of
that that
research yeah so the that is uh my main
project when I start my position so my
first Grand proposal I have
written is about
probiotic basically potentially curing
parasite problem in developing countries
such as Africa so I submit that
idea and
to Melinda and Bill Gates Foundation
more than I think almost 10 years ago
and then I got the money
and that is a super
honor because Bill Gates even
posted my project in his
Facebook and I even didn't know because
I was not social media person until
three years
ago and then I found out you know
because my friend
said how do you
know Bill
and then my answer was everyone know B
Gage what are you talking about and then
he said no no no no no I meant why he
put your picture and your project in his
Facebook and then I also surprised and
honored at the time and that is all
about figure I made using
Microsoft was
Microsoft yeah of course and then he
probably love it in some sense and but
the problem we wanted to solve is very
important problem because many people
especially in Africa especially young
kid infected by
parasite and then you know suffering
from those
disease because they don't have
infrastructure in terms of the you know
clean water and clean environment
so our idea is basically we wanted to
use synthetic biology
concept probiotic
potentially equipped with the sensor the
bio sensor that biosensor detect
parasite and then once parasite
detected probiotic generate
some
molecule that potentially kill
parasite you know by you know producing
some chemical or some molecule that
specifically killing parasite so that
was
idea and then since that we want need to
expand the same
concept you may you know be surprised if
I say bacteria are smart or bacteria are
very smart because bacteria also sense
environment they don't have eyes or ears
but they or nose but they still sense in
bottom because of that we could
manipulate bacterial
Gene to make them to sense even human
disease and also bacteria also produce
lots of
molecule for example you probably
already heard about
antibiotics antibiotic actually produced
by the
bacteria so for some disease bacteria
could also produce some molecule that
potentially cure the human disease so
basically that's our concept bacteria
want sense some human disease and then
bacteria produce a molecule for
human so so to do so I wanted to use
some Bine or safe bacteria and one of
them is a
probiotic so I want to ask do you drink
or take yogurt um yeah on occasions I do
yes on occasion okay yogurt is very good
for the health without any manipulation
but my idea is I wanted to make yogurt
that contain my engineered
bacteria because the typical probiotic
in yogurt cannot sense
disease but I want to make this bacteria
sense disease or some other symptom you
may have and then I want to give one
example that is something interesting to
many audience I
believe let me ask one
question have you heard about
about
neurochemicals or
neurotransmitters found in your backook
um yeah so I should clarify to my
audience that we have had this
conversation uh before but uh yes uh
seratonin is one I know that got
microbiome
producers sure so serotonin is one of
the great
example serotonin you made
heard about but serotonin in fact
produced by your G cell rather than your
brain cell more than
90% produced by your bu so that's very
interesting or
shocking fact when I heard that you know
report many years ago because I thought
thought I'm human and all the
neurochemical that control my mood
happiness should be produced by my brain
cell not by
God and then I realize God feeling might
be true because you know serotonin
produced by my God cell more than
90% another important fact I want to
mention is
bacteria total number of
bacteria we have in our
body the number is more than much higher
than total number of human cell we have
so you believe you are human but you are
human plus more bacterial cell you
carrying every
day and then as you can imagine you have
more bacterial cell bacteria influence
us and one of the way bacteria influence
us is bacteria also have ability to
metabolize
neurochemical that found in your gut and
also synthesize your
chemical so after I thinking about
this all fact and then I come up with
some crazy
idea so one day if I successfully
implement the idea
I want you to take my yogurt that yogurt
contain my probiotic and then this
probiotic sense
serotonin because serotonin is one of
the important neurochemical control your
mood and
happiness and then let's say your
serotonin level from 30 to 100 that's
the good level for you to be happy
and then bacteria send and if the level
is between that right
range your bacteria now start to produce
pigment let's say the green
color if you see your poop I'm sorry I'm
talking about poop again if you see your
poop after you take my yogurt and if
that's a green color today is the happy
happy day because your curn a is just
right and then you just enjoy your happy
day today tomorrow unfortunately C Level
also
fluctuate and tomorrow your level is too
high or too low and then bacteria start
to produce in response to that
concentration Now red
color and today is unhappy day so stay
at home don't do anything stupid it and
just until your C Level become right
level so this is a diagnostic
application your bacteria tell you by
showing
color in your poop basically you are
happy or not
happy that's one application but why we
stay there because you could have better
or accurate measurement of your serator
level not just got seron level but even
blood serotonin level that's more
important because that is basically
affecting your brain even though G level
influence your blood level because that
circulate or
culate you could go to hospital and take
your blood and then a couple of days
later you will say you will see the your
Leger but that's too probably late
because that's is only telling you new
two days ago serotonin level so what I
want to do is Real Time detection of
Serotonin using
Pro but my near CRA idea is not just
detecting serotonin but I wanted to
control
serotonin like we control temperature in
the
room so in the room we have summer step
and if summer St working fine if the
temperature is too
high yeah conditioner start to cooling
down but if the loom temperature too low
and the heater start and then making the
temperature rise same thing for the
serotonin control if your bacteria sense
and then if bacteria produce enzyme that
break down serotonin
in response to high concentration of
Serotonin you can make serotonin level
go down or below the 100 that's our
thresold in terms of Happiness
level if the seron level is too low you
could make bacteria respond to that and
then produce enzyme that synthesize
serotonin in that way serotonin level
become higher than 30 that is our
threshold we kind of you know
determine so having the same idea we
call it Dynamic control or temperature
control uh the same way as the
temperature control in the
room if that's possible you know we
could make your setor level always stay
in the some certain range and then I
already have my commercial punch line
and then that punch line sound like do
you want to be happy yes yeah take
my you will be always always happy so
that's my punch right but as you can
imagine this is crazy idea and then that
takes a lot of years of research and
optimization because each individual
different in terms of diet and complex
it of the microbiome in your gut and
then your your level of the serotonin
fluctuate so you need to make the sensor
that kick enough to respond to serotonin
level and then that is also fluctuating
at the same time you need to make the
bacteria survive or behave well with
other bacteria but the composition of
bacteria in your God different from my
God so how to make personalized Medicine
by making one yogurt that contain the
same probiotic so this is the bunch of
different challenges we need to overcome
to make that crazy dream come true but I
still wanted to Dream High because that
is why not because that may potentially
help a lot of people become
happier that's my uh sort of crazy idea
I want to improve yeah no I mean for
sure it's a really compelling idea and I
think this is again what attracted me to
synthetic biology is just like how
creative you can be and obviously once
you've got the system in place or some
way of getting the bacteria into the
body through the yogurt in this case you
can just change the sensor and change
the enzymes within the system so it's
not serotonin it's it's all sorts of
different molecules that it could be
sensing and responding to but as you
mentioned it seems like uh there are
many other challenges associated with
building this in a first place some of
that's also probably a lack of our own
understanding of what's happening in the
G microbiome at the moment the different
species presence and different people
but another challenge is also getting
the the probiotics to persist in the the
gut for a period of time to be able to
respond dynamically to the changes but
then also while you want them to persist
there are other concers you don't want
them to persist necessarily too long or
to escape and to start you know' got
genetically modified bacteria there's a
lot of uh like safety concerns
potentially about this and I know you've
also done well a lot of research on uh
bi containment um by remediation and
develop these really awesome kill
switches and so I think it' be awesome
to hear about
that sure thank you so that's the
brilliant question
so
as you mentioned bio containment is very
important issue because all
I try to build
or construct is SoCal
GMO and then even my wife and my
daughter hate GMO and I
believe American is more generous toward
GMO but many people in European country
including UK people literally hate Gio
and I also had one experience almost 10
years ago I had debate with a famous
former youth
anchor after one and a half hour debate
his conclusion
was I am making GMO and I am bad guy
because I'm making a GMO so that was
conclusion so since that I specially
interest
in BIO
containment because we watch too many
horror
movie in that movie basically bacteria
become monster even dinosaur or whatever
monster destroy the Earth or planet and
then and then we need to prevent that
one so since that we try to develop
multiple from uh k switch I call it the
K switch concept is something like this
as I mentioned
earlier this probiotic let's say
successfully cure disease in your
gut the disease could be you know some
other disease not necessarily only
serotonin level control but let's say
cure uh some pathogenic in infection by
you know gen generating some molecule or
that could be some metabolic disease you
know because of the metab you know some
molecule accumulate beyond the safety
level in that way sometime people die if
you have some genetic
disease and then that is our mission we
given to bacteria let's say the mission
accomplished unfortunately that's still
GMO and then the GMO will be released
into the environment with your
poop so in that scenario or the other
scenario would be bacteria also
mutate because that is what we see in
the movies and then that may happen in
your gut even before you miss you know
your mission
accomplished there are many beneficial
bacteria in your God but how can we make
make the specific bacteria we generate
or
GMO kill in a targeted way so that was a
question I want to answer so recently we
you know
demonstrated after seven years of
failure because we fighting
against
mutation because we try to kill bacteria
bacteria always find some way to
mutate their gen or the k switch in that
way in a
survive but main idea is something like
this if bacteria become bad guy we could
give some chemical that
specifically
Target our bacteria and then bacteria
start to die and that's the main concept
but as I mentioned we constantly fail
because mutation
always happen and then our bacteria
somehow
survive and then you know bacteria kind
of prop propur you know basically making
more bacteria and then kind of dominate
the
population let me ask the question to
you let's say we start
10 to the 11
cell per
ML and then let's say I kill all the
bacteria except one
bacteria to give some idea 10 to the 11
cell is a lot of cell if you doing my
biology research microbiology you
probably heard about OD 600 for
eoli OD of one is 10 to the 9 cell per
ml each but now I'm talking about 10 to
the 11 cell that's 100 times more than
you typically see in the
laboratory that is only achievable by
doing high glucose
fermentation very dense equoli
culture if I
talking about 10 to the 11 cell going
down to the one
bacterium is it
success or failure well I mean if that's
one surviving it can grow I suppose
but so one surviving is not success
exactly okay let me give some another
idea the US NH
guideline is if you start with the 10 to
the a
cell and then at the end of day you have
only one
Survivor they are okay with
that but I start with the 10 to the 11
cell that's a three order of magnitude
higher that meet NIH
guideline but you still think that's not
success yeah I guess
so right so that is probably correct
answer
because
scientifically last 30 years of
research
GMO because GMO has additional
burden that is not their goal because
bacteria do not care about our goal
because bacteria do not care about
helping us bacteria do not care about
curing our disease bacteria only want it
to
survive but we
put some curing molecule and sensor
that's a additional homework they want
to gain it of by
mutating
right so that's why we struggle we
constantly battle against
mutation and then that's how you know we
almost fail every single time last seven
years because of
mutation however because your bacteria
has additional
burden the survive you know the ability
to survive in the Real
Environment typically almost
zero compared to the native bacteria in
the
environment that is 30 years of
data however as you
mention public do not see that way
because we watch too many
movies and we don't know what would be
the consequence this one bacterium in
the
environment so as a scientist and
engineer we need to responsible for what
we doing
so I wanted to completely
eliminate even just one
bacterium even though we start with the
10 to the 11 cell or even higher number
of
cell but as I said that's very difficult
problem so my student Austin you know
constantly fail because we done multiple
different approach to improve killing
efficiency but always there are another
m ation happening in the kill
switch and then one point I was sitting
in the hospital waiting for my doctor
for two hours because somehow us
hospital system is sort of messed up so
even though you book your spot you need
to wait two hours so I have nothing to
do except
daying and what I realized at that time
or
after crazy daydreaming I start to think
about what happening if we lose
electricity in this
Hospital the patient who almost died
under operation doctor could do
operation the answer is fortunately
yes in most developed country they have
backup
generator or always kick in whenever we
lose
power after thinking about that one why
not we could have multiple kill
switch not only one but several of kill
switch because mutation happening
random if somehow
mutation randomly destroy kill switch we
still have several more kill switch to
act
so after we putting total four kill
switch Even though three was sufficient
but I want to have one more in that way
we make sure extra one more probably
doesn't hurt but technologically that
was very challenging but we achieve it
and then after we have four kill
switch and we tested that kill s in the
mouse
model now all the but bacteria we
provide into the mouse and then Mouse if
we give the specific
chemical the k switch containing
bacteria will die regardless of the
number of cell we originally putting
in at the same time we want to make sure
bacteria do not survive in the
environment to implement that idea we
wanted to use the difference between our
temperature that is typically body
temperature is typically
37 and outside that's typically a little
bit below or around 30° even during the
hot
summer of in Africa because at night
temperature go down so the idea is
basically
bacteria come out of your body and
temperature drop
and then your temperature sensors
basically detect the temperature down
sift and then basically bacteria start
to produce kill
switch molecule in that way bacteria
just start to
die so we demonstrated using again my
favorite subject Mouse poop and we
collect it and then we demonstrate in
the 30°
and the other into the
37 and then only we saw Survivor at
37 that is kind of mimicking the same
concent same temperature in the body but
we didn't see any bacteria at the 30
degree because the kill switch basically
kill all the
bacteria nice so you mentioned you had
up to four kill sets and so these
orthogonal so you have chemicals as one
of them temperature another and so what
are the different sort of signals that
can trigger the kill
switch that is a great question so we
use the either chemical or temperature
also we use both of them together at the
same time this kill switch is orthogonal
because their sequence is different that
means even if your mutation process
somehow destroy one kill switch you
still have the three more other
intact until you destroy all four of
them you know your kill switch basically
working I didn't you know explain all
the detail how the kill switch working
because that might be too technical but
to give some idea we use so-called
crisper system you probably heard about
the name crisper because that is the one
topic you know Nobel Prize you you know
basically given but crisper is the
molecular seizure that cut
DNA human and eukariotic system all has
So-Cal non homos Endo joining
mechanism in that way even if your DNA
cut DNA join together and then repair
themselves but fortunately for us most
of the bacteria do not have so-called
nonhomologous end joining mechanism that
means if you cut the
DNA the Genome of DNA bacteria cannot
Stitch that together and bacteria in
theory
die unless the kill switch or crisper
system has mutation that make the Mal
function of kill switch so that's basic
idea so as long as we have
intact one kill switch
exist always The Cutting happen and then
bacteria die nice yeah no I see that's
really cool um so what like I'm very
interested in like where your sort of
creative ideas come from and sort of
like how do you go about Reading
literature or like synthesizing ideas
from different areas
together so how I come up with the crazy
idea that's
your sure uh because the
GU no no the the let me put it this way
so I used to
be very shy you know thinking about
things very in a safe
way so I was typical average Professor
you know
before but one event completely changed
my
perspective so uh what happened was you
know I
was uh professor and then one of my Prof
you know student actually coming from
Africa but unfortunately you know he was
you know black guy you know because of
his race uh he was sort of
discriminated by the leadership people
in the
university and he's almost kicked out of
the
University also almost kicked out of the
US and at the time I was on tenure
Professor you know I decide to keep
quiet to protect myself at the same time
protect my
student that was just my excuse I would
say and since that I was so
ashamed of being
Professor because I could not speak up
at the time to save my family or my
career and then I became so sick uh for
many years
literally
dying for almost four years and then in
the year of
2020 when everyone suffered
from
covid I didn't care about covid much
because I thought that in that year I
thought I just die anyway regardless of
covid because of my symptom and
pains that is combine pain from mental
stress at the same time real physical
pain every single day or every single
second almost four
years when You Face your death I
guess you could
do whatever you want to do including
something you never
imagine so that year before I
die I wanted
to put my crazy idea I thinking about
let's say more than 10 years but I never
put into the
reality so I put five
proposal collecting all the crazy idea
together and as submitted hoping that is
selected after I
die and interestingly I miraculously
survive in some because of some
event and then all five idea was funded
nice and since that I
realized I want to solve many Global
problem I believe total 10 problem I
want to
solve but just
incremental advance of knowledge cannot
solve this biggest problem we currently
facing including climate crisis food you
know shortage you know sustainable
production and also medicine problem or
pandemic I believe after that we should
have some Innovative or
potentially disruptive technology should
be developed to solve many of this kind
of problem so since that I only thinking
about crazy problem or crazy ideas
because the small project can be
done by some other people but somebody
should be
crazy to you know show some potential
disruptive you know solution so that's
how how I you know became a crazy guy in
some sense why think isas have some a
lot of backing to them and they're very
exciting uh so yeah I'm glad that you've
pulled through and got funding for these
different projects I'm curious as well
though to hear uh like what sort of
advice would you give to other students
who are interested in joining synthetic
biology as a field or where should they
go to find out uh like to come up with
ideas or what should they be
studying sure uh you know I have though
just one
advice as I mentioned earlier you know
I've experienced very dramatic you know
life experience that start from
discrimination and harassment based on
race but I'm not the only one I believe
many student
and you know International
Scholars or you know just young people
in
general they constantly worrying about
things because the world we currently
living in there are too many sad news or
gloomy news including
Wars in including the
Ukraine
Israel
Palestine and also hunger
in country like Africa
countries and there are too many other
also you know simply you just broke up
with your girlfriend or boyfriend and
life is full of crazy sad things
happening to us but I want to say you
are not the only one having those kind
of thing but at the same
time you also remember happy moment in
your life because of something
you care
about I'll give one example that Sav my
life in some sense or
partially and that's great story and
then to give my
advice the student I just
mentioned who originated from Africa
discriminated because he is black
guy so basically racial discrimination
and
harassment he suffered from that one and
then you know have difficult time for
many many years almost kick out of the
school and almost kick out of the
university
and
country because he didn't have any
power
but sort of I proud of myself because I
protect him in some sense sort of Ja
izing my career as
well and after he endured that all the
difficulty he finally managed to join a
company I believe you already know the
company that is the
fer and then he joined the special task
force by utilizing all the knowledge he
learned from the University from me to
develop the firstc covid vaccine at
fiser and then he became a world hero
wow or at least hero known to all the
African continent people who interest in
research in
biotechnology because of him I getting
too many email from Africa for your
information but one thing I want to tell
you is
one
great thing I learned from him was he
has much more difficulty than me for
example his home in Africa when he was
studying here he didn't have
electricity let alone
internet his mom suffering from cancer
still suffering from
cancer but he saved his
salary even to send the money to the his
family in the US graduate student salary
is very small but still he saved the
salary to support his
family and he endure all the
difficulty you may face but at the end
of day what he done differently from
other normal average student that was he
Dream
High and he never give
up and then he
basically had one
opportunity to join company and then to
join the special force
team they walked every day day and night
and then they
deliver the first covid vaccine to the
entire world
contributing to the
society probably the one of the biggest
problem we face in recent years so my
advice to you is you may have lots of
different problem difficulties
challenges or Injustice whatever you're
facing right now or simply you just
broke up with your girlfriend or
boyfriend listen to it but that is not
the end of your
life just try to learn something from
your experience or even failure because
failure would be the best teacher for
your success in the future and then
Dream High
because I saw many people especially
young people suffering from those kind
of
difficulties but still they living
hoping better
future I know because I travel too much
last year I travel more than 160 days
just to give seminars and meeting people
I did the same thing this year more than
150 days as you can imagine I met a lot
of young
people and even though I mention all the
gloomy sad news
earlier but I was so
optimistic I am so optimistic at this
moment because of you because I saw the
future and potential and passion to
solve all the global problem that could
be Injustice hunger or climate problem
or whatever problem you care about
because I saw huge passion from you you
want to solve this problem and then if
you solve that problem we'll have the
better World 20 years
later potentially we don't have those
kind of problem or at least we solve
many of the
problem but that all depend on you and
then you should be proud of yourself
because you still
living despite of all the difficulty and
then you will become of better
leaders to make this world better
place in that way I will
benefit because my daughter will live in
a better world because of you
yeah one sentence Dream High never give
up
and failure will teach you and make you
stronger see true um it's just been
incredible to talk to you T and you've
been an incredible role model and you're
doing some very worthwhile research
yourself and I can only wish you the
best of luck with all of your undav and
hopefully we'll see them in short at
some point um so yeah it's just been
great talking to you and I wish you the
best of
success thank you it's my great honor to
talk with you and I I hope to see many
global leaders in the future among this
audience